[Music]
well good afternoon everyone
so glad that you could join us for our
live
program i'd like to know i have with me
as usual brother james rafferty
uh he is associate speaker here at
secrets unsealed and we're very glad to
have him with us
good to be here very well versed on
scripture i might say
um i just want to mention something
about ca
some people have been emailing and
asking where ca is
well i can assure you that he's in
panama
and the reason he's in panama he's been
there actually for a couple of months
is because his mother-in-law is 101
years old i think
and she's not in good health and of
course his wife is down there
and they have some things to take care
of with the house that they're
remodeling
and so he hasn't been able to be with us
but they're doing fine
and we're planning to have them back in
the near future
so i just want to let everybody know
also
if you want to send us your questions
because this is a
question and answer program you can do
so at the address that you're going to
find on the screen
tv at some tv dot org once again tv at
some tv
dot org send us your questions we'll do
the research
and if the question has an answer if
it's not a mystery
that is only in the hands of god we'll
do everything possible to answer it amen
so we want to begin with the word of
prayer as we always do
so i'd like to ask pastor rafferty if he
would absolutely
you bet let's pray father just want to
thank you again for
your word and the fact that it is
foundational to our experience
and that you speak to us through it and
because it's inspired and because
human agents were used to to pen it
there are sometimes
questions that we have things that
aren't really clear and we
have viewers that have asked some
questions today some good questions some
pertinent questions and we're just
praying now pausing in your presence
and asking your holy spirit will guide
us as we seek for answers in your word
and we're asking this now in jesus name
amen amen
okay i am going to throw this question
at
pastor rafferty okay
my question is touchy so let me first
say
i do believe jesus is the son of god
okay
and that he took on human nature and was
tempted
as we are okay that said
i'd like to know how it is that jesus
walked this earth
and it is said he did not use his divine
power for himself
yet he told nathan he saw him
actually it means nathanael he saw him
under the fig tree
earlier that day also before gethsemane
the bible says the angels came and
comforted
him to strengthen him before his passion
here's my thought i don't have the
ability as a human
to see anyone under a fig tree and i
don't have holy angels that come and
comfort me
in my hour of need like jesus had
and i don't have the ability to go to
the mountain top and see moses and
elijah
and a cloud come down like jesus did
or like the woman at the well he had
full knowledge of her life
so how can it be said that jesus didn't
have an advantage
he could read people's thoughts and
also foresee their actions how about
mary magdalene
and how he wrote the sins of the people
around in the sand
with his finger as a human i cannot do
those things
again it is always seen to me
that jesus did have an advantage that i
do not have
i do not say that lightly or
disrespectfully
could you discuss that thank you so much
for considering my questions
and god bless great questions mouthful
great questions really long questions
you know
i let's just start with one point and
maybe we can just build build a bill
because there's so much here that we
could talk about so i'm just going to
start with the first point
and that or one point here and that is
the bible says angels came and comforted
him and strengthened him before his
passion and
she goes on here to talk about how i
don't have the ability
um to see people on the fig tree and i
don't have angels that come and comfort
me in my hour of need
and the first person i thought of when i
read that other than christ was elijah
you remember elijah was struggling and
he ran from jezebel
he went 30 days but the first time he
stopped
the angels came to minister to him and
then he went again and the angels came
again to minister to him
and i think about this in the bible it
says you know are not
they all ministering spirit sent forth
to minister to them who by the heirs of
salvation
hebrews chapter 1 yes so we may not
think
that we're in the same situation as
christ but the bible says that christ
became a man just like us
that he could do nothing of himself and
the very thing that we see happening in
christ's life is the very thing we see
happening in the lives of other biblical
characters
and even by faith in our lives we don't
if our eyes could be open we would see
angels ministering to us we'd see angels
all around us
evil angels as well as good angels but
the because there's a battle taking
place for
the decision the termination of our will
and our souls so i think that
while i would understand where they're
coming from because maybe not on the
level of the way that christ was
ministered to
in the garden of gethsemane let's say
but definitely
on on the level of
the reality through faith that the
angels ministered to us
yes we are christ has no advantage over
us in that sense
because angels come to minister to us
just like they did to him yeah
you know i think that um and all of the
examples that this person gives
i think can be explained by the fact
that jesus while he was on earth
did everything in harmony with his
father's will
as the father revealed to him each day
what he needed to know
let's read some verses uh john chapter
five
all of these are in the gospel of john
by the way um
it's this thought is repeated time and
time and time again
19 and 20. john 5 verse 20 or 19 or yeah
okay 20.
let's see here i was thinking of
19 verse 20 for the father loveth the
son
and shows him all things that he himself
does
and he will show him greater works than
these that ye may marvel
in in fact in verse 19 and and then
answered jesus and said unto them verily
verily i send you
the son can do nothing of himself so
you've got both points right here
right and uh you know let's just read a
few of these okay verse 30 to 32
yep same chapter verse 30 to 32. i can
of my own self do nothing as i hear i
judge and my judgment is just
because i seek not mine own will but the
will of the father
which has sent me if i bear witness of
myself my witness is not true
32 there is another that bears witness
of me i know that that witness which he
witnesses of me
is true so so basically once again the
same thought
notice john 4 34.
john 4 30. this comes through time and
again in the gospel of john
uh john 4 34. jesus said unto them
my meat is to do the will of him that
sent me and to finish his work
do the will of the father it was the
father 6 38.
i can do nothing of myself i do what i
see
what he shows me 6 38
for i came down from heaven not to do my
own will but the will of him that sent
me
so and i have several others i just
mentioned them uh john 7 15 and 16
john 8 28 john 12 49
john 17 verse 8 john 20 20 23 john 14
20.
we could continue on and on jesus did
not come to do his will
he did the father's will and the father
revealed his will to jesus
each day and depended on him now think
about
god's prophets they were shown things
about other people
you remember when i can't remember the
king's name now but he complained that
everywhere he went
the israelites knew where he was going
and his counselor said well elisha
is god is showing elijah what you're
doing you see same thing
elijah's a human being but not all of us
are called to be a prophet not all of us
are called to be elijah and all of us
are called to be elijah not all of us
are called to that
level of experience not all of us are
called to the level of experience jesus
had
as our savior but it doesn't mean that
angels aren't sent to minister to us
as we need them or when we need them
right
maybe we can look at some statements
from the spirit of prophecy
on this particular point okay
in desire of ages 208 because jesus
calmed the storm
jesus resurrected the dead you know they
say he had powers that we don't have
but uh did he actually do that or was it
someone else who was doing it through
him okay desire ages 208
so utterly was christ emptied of self
that he made no plans for himself he
accepted god's plans for him
and now comes the key portion and day by
day
the father unfolded his plans
so should we depend upon god that
our lives may be the simple outworking
of his will
so he had no advantage that we don't
have uh as far as the
the miracles that jesus performed uh
desire of ages page 143 spectacular
statement
the angels of god are ever passing from
heaven from earth to heaven
and from heaven to earth the miracles of
christ for the afflicted and suffering
were wrought by the power of god
through the ministration of the angels
and it is through christ by the
ministration of his heavenly messengers
that every blessing comes from god to us
amen so she says what happened to jesus
can also happen to us well think about
the early church you know
some people went out just they were
shocked when peter and john went to pray
they made a lame man on the way he had a
song that's where i saw him
and this is what they'd say you know
silver and gold are right now but such i
have gave the name of jesus christ to
rise take up your bed and walk right
yeah
and or maybe it wasn't taking up your
bed but arise and walk and so
he they said that when paul would pass
by they would try to get into a shadow
yeah all of these miracles that seemed
to be only applicable to christ would
now be manifest
in the early church because they were
filled with the holy spirit and the
heavenly angels of god what about paul
resurrecting eutychus
breaking the dead what about peter being
able to read the minds of ananias and
sapphira
yes peter couldn't read the minds of
ananias and sapphira
it was the holy ghost god through the
angels yes through the ministry of the
holy ghost the foot soldiers of the
holy spirit are the angels you know they
actually told peter these people are
lying
so uh if we're real close to christ
god can guide our steps each day as well
and there's
there's nobody that was as connected to
god as christ was
so the level of his experience was
definitely higher than any human being
only because that connection was
unprecedented in the human race
unprecedented
but not impossible for human beings
to experience as well right this is a
phenomenal statement desire of ages page
and christ was not to exercise divine
power for his own benefit
he had come to bear trial as we must do
leaving us an example of faith and
submission
neither here nor at any subsequent time
in his earthly life did he work a
miracle
in his own behalf his wonderful works
were all
for the good of others and uh
you know the angels had a very important
role of course
during the ministry of christ ellen
white says that all of the miracles of
christ were performed
by the power of god through the
ministration of the angels
so uh and when jesus was going to
resurrect lazarus he prays he says
father i'm glad that you've heard me yes
so and you always hear me so jesus had
no advantage bottom line that we can't
have
right if we have the same level of
commitment that jesus has
but his level of commitment was never
broken so we can see things in his life
you know that we wouldn't necessarily
experience only because
can you imagine being born of the holy
spirit right from your birth
now we're born again of the holy spirit
so we begin at certain time and we
experience
the reality of that connection jesus
always had that from the very beginning
right so we shouldn't be overwhelmed by
the idea
that jesus did and experienced things
that you know were
extraordinary but you know so so we see
in
others who are totally connected with
god enoch walk with god
and he was not for god took him and that
can be the experience of god's people in
the end of time in fact you know the
last generation of god's people will be
translated without seeing death
yeah their walk with god is going to be
so close and she says
ella white states in great controversy
that god's people will perform powerful
miracles
when the loud cry when the holy spirit
is poured out in the loud cry power but
we can't depend on those
because they'll be counterfeited true
but they'll still be there true they
will be there yes
um let me just give here a couple of
examples
of uh you know supernatural things that
appeared that jesus
did but really it was the power of the
father that did it remember the the
calming of the storm
in desire of ages 3 36 ellen white wrote
when jesus was awakened to meet the
storm
he was in perfect peace there was no
trace of fear
in word or look for no fear was in his
heart
now here comes the key portion but he
rested not in the possession
of almighty power it was not
as the master of earth sea and sky
that he reposed in quiet that power
he had laid down and he says i
can of mine own self do nothing john 5
30 he trusted in the father's might
it was by faith faith in god's love and
care
that jesus rested and the power of that
word
which stilled the storm was the power of
god and we know that satan
tried to get him to use his divine power
oh yeah do you remember when he tempted
him in the wilderness
and he said if you're the son of god
turn these stones into bread
and when was the last time you were
tempted to turn stones into bread
we can't do that but jesus could have
done it yes if he would have tapped into
his own divine power
and that's what satan was trying to do
satan was trying to get jesus to rely
upon himself
just like he tries to get us to rely
upon ourselves jesus refused
right he depended on god just like we
can depend on god
sure he had no advantage over us that we
can't have right as we depend on god
yeah
we can become participants
of divine by nature of the divine nation
having overcome the corruptions that are
in the world through lust
absolutely maybe i can just read
one more quotation when jesus
died on the cross the last statement
that he made was father into your hands
i commend my spirit
now why did jesus say father into your
hands i commend my spirit
because they had agreed that jesus would
only resurrect if his father called him
from the tomb
there's this remarkable statement in the
youth's instructor
may 2 1901 where ellen white wrote he
who died for the sins of the world
was to remain in the tomb for the
allotted time
he was in that stony prison house as a
prisoner of divine justice
and he was responsible to the judge of
the universe
he was bearing the sins of the world and
his father
only could release him wow and the
interesting thing is
that you know people use john 10 17 and
where jesus says i have power to lay my
life down and i have power to take it up
again
the word power there by the way is
exusia which should be translated i have
authority
okay power is dunamis so jesus says i
have authority
to lay down my life and i have authority
to take it up and where is that found
again
that's in john 10. okay but but then
they forget to read the last
part of that yeah a verse 18.
uh you want to read that verse yeah john
10 verse 18
no man taketh it from me but i've uh i
lay it down of myself
i have power to lay it down i have power
to take it up again this commandment
have i received of my father
so the way it worked was that on
resurrection morning
two angels came down from heaven one
took away the stone sat on it
the other one stood before the tomb like
ellen white describes and said oh thou
son of god my father calls me i love
that
he had commanded his spirit into the
hands of his father and now his father
is authorizing him to take
back the life that was within himself it
wasn't the father's life
that brought him from the tomb it was
his life that brought him from the tomb
but by authority of the father and
that's really important because we can
get confused on that you know
jesus came forth from the tomb for by
the life that was in himself
but that authority came from the father
yep i love that because jesus has always
been subject to his father's authority
even in eternity past the father had to
explain the real position of his son in
heavenly counsel with lucifer
so anyway that's i hope that that helps
in answering this question let's go to
the next one
uh this one is very interesting uh it
says this
i'd like to know or have a better
understanding of how revelation
put 18 10 but it's really 1910 14 12 and
19 17.
that should be 12 17 also yeah he's uh
he's assuming that the faith of jesus
is the same as the testimony of jesus
but it isn't uh yeah
so it's revelation 19 verse 10
technically revelation 12 17
isaiah chapter 8 verse 20 and i would
add revelation 22 verses 8 and 9.
um so this is the question if so
how they relate to the spirit of
prophecy and sister white's
writings uh in other words as they're
called in other words
the question is it's not really phrased
easily to read
it's phrased as to the testimony of
jesus does that only apply to illinois
the expression spirit of prophecy right
or does it have a broader sense of
everyone who was inspired by the holy
spirit who wrote in scripture
right that's the question yes so that's
what the question is that this sister is
asking
and you know the verses she's talking
about are really significant because
they identify a remnant church
and this remnant church in revelation 12
has the testimony of jesus which in
revelation 19 10 is
identified as the spirit of prophecy
the remnant church is the remnant of
what or the remnant of the woman
it's the last part of the woman god's
church
that goes back to the jewish age if you
read revelation 12 even very carefully
because christ comes forth from this
woman
so a remnant church is identified as
having those
things that are going to be part of the
original church
does that make sense you've got a
remnant of the original so she's going
to have the church is going to have
those things that the original has
and so when you go when you look at the
spirit of prophecy we identify the
spirit of prophecy you know in the last
days
god's end time prophecy is elon white
and we recognize that she is a
continuation
of the prophets of god it's not a
singular
manifestation of that gift but it's
something that is a continuation
and part of the remnant church something
that's already been manifest and now is
being manifested again in the end of
time
so basically the reason why it's called
the spirit of prophecy
is because the holy spirit inspired the
prophets to write
prophecy to give prophecy um maybe we
can read some bible verses
on this particular point uh first peter
chapter 1 verses 10 through 12.
you have the holy spirit involved and
you have also the the
prophets and you have the spirit okay
first peter 1
beginning verse 10 uh verses 10 through
12. okay
of which salvation the prophets have
inquired and searched diligently
who prophesied of the grace that should
come unto you
searching water what manner of time the
spirit of christ which was in them did
signify when it testified beforehand
the sufferings of christ and the glory
that should follow okay let's just stop
right there
so this is talking about the old
testament prophets that prophesied about
christ
and his sufferings and it's suffering so
the question is
how did they know that well it says the
spirit of christ was in them
[Music]
wow so they're prophesying the spirit of
christ is in them so it's the spirit of
prophecy
now let's read verse 12. and it's the
testimony of jesus christ and it's the
testimony of jesus christ they're very
closely related right unto whom it was
revealed that not unto themselves but
unto
us did they minister the things which
are now reported unto you by them
that have preached the gospel unto you
with the holy ghost
sent down from heaven which things the
angels desire to look into
so there you have the holy spirit the
spirit of christ
and the prophets who prophesied about
christ through the spirit of christ yes
so that's why it's called the spirit of
prophecy yes that's good
let's read zechariah 7 verse 12.
zechariah
7 12. that's right on the other side of
malachi right yep that's
uh the next to the last book of the old
testament zechariah chapter 12
chapter 7 verse 12. chapter 7 verse 12
all right
7 verse 12. it says
yea they made their hearts as an adamant
stone lest they should hear the law and
the words which the lord of hosts had
sent
in his spirit by the former prophets
therefore came a great wrath from the
lord of hosts
so it says sent by his spirit through
the former prophets okay
so it's the spirit our prayer
prophecy right right uh let's read one
more second peter 1 21.
second peter went because i'm sure that
those that are watching the program want
a biblical foundation
amen for for the explanation that we're
given
second peter what second peter 1 2 1 20
and 21 21 22
okay knowing this first that no prophecy
of scriptures have any private
interpretation
for the prophecy came not in old time by
the will of man but
holy men of god spake as they were moved
by the holy ghost
so there is a spirit of prophecy holy
men spoke
as they were inspired by the holy spirit
and they spoke prophecy
right so there you have it i mean that's
really clear and you bring this all
together in revelation chapter 12 the
remnant church
is going to have the same care when you
go to a
carpet store and you buy a remnant piece
of carpet it's the leftovers of an
original
the original and the leftovers are going
to be identical so we see the spirit of
prophecy all through the bible
right and the remnant church has that
same gift so definitely we see and
answer this question you know the
question is
i've heard that it's stated sister
white's writings
um is the spirit of prophecy i thought
all the bible as well as sister's rights
writings were considered the spirit of
prophecy as it testifies of jesus
amen amen the person you thought right
that's right you thought right
we're thankful we can help clarify it
yeah so
so uh who was the first person in the
bible that had the spirit of prophecy it
was
enoch
because he prophesied oh that's right
according to jude yeah yeah
he prophesied the seventh from adam yes
all right and then
of course he had the spirit of prophecy
and every
other prophet in scripture had the
spirit of prophecy because the spirit
of christ was in the prophet
testifying about things that would
happen when christ came in his first
coming
and when he comes in his second coming
which by the way the first
prophecy given in scripture genesis 3 15
was given by christ so anything that
connects with that prophecy which of
course predicts the sufferings of christ
and what he would do
is going to be filled with the spirit of
christ right yeah good
so i hope that this uh helps clarify and
by the way why is it called the
testimony of jesus again we know why
it's called the spirit of prophecy why
is it called the testimony of jesus
because it's the spirit of christ that's
in there it testifies of jesus justifies
his sufferings we read that in a
previous verse right testifies of his
sufferings
so isn't that one of the main proofs
of a true prophet is that the true
prophet
testifies to christ and exalts christ
amen
and brings christ to the fore yeah
because when you think about the gift of
the holy spirit you know jesus talked
about the holy spirit coming in john
chapter
16 i believe it is 14-16 and in in 16 he
says
when he comes he's going to testify of
me he's not going to speak about himself
he's going to speak about me
so if a prophet is filled with the holy
spirit that manifestation will be
signaled it'll be manifest in that he
she talks about jesus christ yeah a lot
of people want to be filled with the
holy spirit nowadays and they start
talking about themselves so they start
talking about their private
interpretations or whatever
it is but they're not talking about
jesus we can know when it's a true
manifestation of the holy spirit
because the focus is going to be jesus
christ if they exalt christ yes and you
see that
all through the writings of ellen white
and of course you see it all through the
bible yeah
and the classic book desire of ages
there's no way in the world that you can
read that book
and not see that the central theme
is exalting jesus christ you know my
mother read that book
when i first became an adventist and she
was adamant adamant against the
adventist church i just
catholic roman catholic i'll always be
that you know i was on my her side
and she read that book and she
absolutely loved it she just thought it
was an amazing book you know inspired
she said
yeah well she was right because probably
she didn't know
all the implications of the word
inspired but
it's absolutely true amen well we don't
have time for another question any last
thoughts
well i just i really appreciate the
questions that are coming in i believe
that they help
us to stay sharp you know going through
the bible there's a couple of verses
here that you shared that i'd never seen
before in connection with the spirit of
prophecy there
in first peter and i really really see
that connection it really kind of
so thank you thank the viewers for the
questions that are coming in
keep them coming to tv some tv.org
well i guess it's time for you to end
the program me i've got to end the
program all right
thank you for being with us again and we
look forward to more questions and more
opportunities to sharpen our swords
and to stay connected with the lord
through his word
may god bless you until next time
[Music]
you